all right see if you can follow along
with this uh report from the new york
post
it says
some kind-hearted strangers melted the
internet's heart after contributing 4
500 to a waiter who allegedly was
stiffed by homophobic customers at a
restaurant in madison wisconsin
um
now now
we will show you the
the receipt the note
so it was a bill for 142.95
and then the person this alleged
customer left 142 95 cents and then left
a note they said service was good but we
don't tip sinful homosexuals and sinful
is misspelled
now we have seen
this exact story with almost no changes
at all
um
dozens of times we have seen this
through the years recent years
someone doesn't leave a tip and they
leave a nasty note either it's a note uh
you know it's a
it's an anti-gay or or sometimes it's a
racist note usually it's an anti-gay
thing this this tends to be this is a
genre where most of the entries are uh
are purportedly anti-gay
and
i don't think it's an exaggeration to
say that in every single one of those
cases it's a hoax
every single one has there been yet
a legitimate case of someone leaving a
nasty note on a receipt and it was real
um we're supposed to believe that this
is different now this is this is a real
one
there are already a number of problems
that i think jump out at you
with the fact that this is this is a
genre that is almost always fiction so
that's why immediately there's reason to
suspect
there are other problems too like for
example
um
this is someone who feels that strongly
about it we're supposed to believe i
guess this is a you know a bible banging
christian
we don't tip sinful homosexuals they
don't know how to spell sinful though
that's kind of a little bit of a red
flag
and also they took the time to note that
the service was good
so they they hate this waiter because of
their homosexuality but they love the
service and they made sure to note to
put that down in the note you know the
service was great it was wonderful but
we don't tip you sinful homosexuals
so that's a problem and also how did
they know that the waiter was a
quote-unquote sinful homosexual
does does he introduce himself that way
i've never had a waiter do that i've
never been sitting at applebee's and the
waiter comes up and says uh hey i'm uh
chuck i'll tell you about the specials
today by the way i am a homosexual okay
here are the specials i've never had
that
so a lot of problems a lot of red flags
and also just the fact that you know
those of us who
run in circles with uh conservative
christians we just know that nobody is
doing this
nobody
even if you had someone who was inclined
to leave a note like that that wouldn't
it wouldn't sound like that that would
not be the note that sounds like a note
written by someone who is trying to
sound like what they think a
conservative christian sounds like
but this gets even weirder okay so that
was the note uh going back to the new
york post article it says
uh this is a face this was this was put
up on facebook by a guy named eric
salswedel
and he wrote on facebook to the folks
who felt it was necessary to write this
hateful note and not tip don't worry me
and about 50 250 other others will cover
the tip for you so he um
do we have the facebook post room no we
don't okay so this guy eric salzweedle
he runs a some sort of non-profit
and this is in madison wisconsin he's
the not he's a he runs a non-profit
group called do good wisconsin
and
he originally
he wasn't he was not the waiter
but he got his hands
on this receipt from someone who doesn't
say who it was from someone some some
poor waiter some poor homosexual waiter
gave him the receipt he eric salzweedle
posted it to his own facebook page
and solicited donations to himself
he put his own personal paypal and venmo
up and said hey everybody uh someone
left this note for uh you know a waiter
i'm not gonna tell you who the waiter is
and i'm not gonna tell you who left the
note doesn't matter uh but it's a
terrible thing why don't you give me
money and then i'm gonna go to the
restaurant and leave a massive tip with
your money to that poor waiter and
people did it
people sent him 4 500 and then he did a
follow-up facebook post later saying
claiming that he went to the restaurant
and gave the 4 500
to the to the waiter and he never told
us who it was anyway i tracked this eric
salzweed old guy down on twitter
and um
i asked him i said i said hey do you
have any
you were soliciting donations to your
personal paypal account
based on this receipt
and we don't know who any of these
people are
do you have any proof that any of this
is real that it's not a hoax
like how do we know that you're not
perpetrating a hoax or maybe the waiter
perpetrator to hoax against you i mean
how do we know
and we i went back and forth with the
guy on twitter a few times and you could
go on my on my twitter page and see the
back and forth he the the long and short
answer is that he is not going to be
providing any evidence that any of this
is real he said i'm not making this up
he said he's not going to provide
evidence that it's real because i
wouldn't believe it anyway even if he
did
okay so you
you look
i'm i'm naturally a skeptic i admit it
uh
you decide for yourself whether this
sounds legitimate to you eric salzweedle
took a receipt
said i don't know i'm not going to tell
you who this is from or he did tell me
it was a friend of a friend so
his friend has a friend and then he got
the receipt from them but he's not going
to tell the person's name doesn't matter
doesn't matter who left it none of that
matters
just give him uh five thousand dollars
and he'll and he'll make it all right
and and hundreds of people actually said
that that sounds totally legitimate to
me
even though this story is has been a
hoax 100 of the time in the past
and this is actually the least credible
sounding one we've heard yet
i'm gonna give this guy my money
my god
but you know what if you're that stupid
you deserve to be scammed
it's pretty clear to me you got scammed
that's my theory i don't know for a fact
i think
[Music]
and uh you absolutely deserve it in that
case
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated